GTA on PC hasn't been out for too long
but the mods are already starting to
come out Rob they are coming in hot and
they're already so good it kind of all
started out with Alexander blade made a
post for a native trainer it came with a
few pieces that basically got the ball
rolling and just started a whole bunch
of mods coming out over the last few
weeks yeah exactly but yeah let's take a
look at that first one right yeah this
is the native trainer the sample ASI
that came with it and if you pop that in
using f4 BAM you'll immediately get so
many options from just kind of pimping
out your player you can change his skin
color it's really like it's everything
it's everything you see GTA you can
become so Michael ah you can be like
hahahaha what are you saying I'm like
why did he like a chicken of course the
really amusing ones are the animals so
Ralph the bag yeah your pig it's a
little hood hog oh so this also lets you
spawn so you can or you can teleport
anywhere in the map so it can be a cow
and then let's go back let's go back
here at kemah port oster club mr. crowd
Bessie wants some hot action tonight yes
he does indeed give it a 4 y se check
out the udders on that one bet you never
saw a girl like this most the time you
have to pay extra for the vent daddy
like one again do not harm the stripper
so yeah I don't know if you knew this
mary is that uh oh one green why if you
can do different like shades of the dog
oh that's pretty cool
I have a good time you know it man I'm
gonna get a private no cash pull it out
again if I can get some money out of my
wallet hey mr. doggy likes to hug rather
weird Chuck uh-oh trigger when can't do
it when the guys looking at it keep your
hands to yourself you know what to do as
much I'm trying not to it was like the
thing oh it totally did Master pick me
up I got kicked out of the ship clubbing
yeah all right oh yeah yeah oh you
looked really good when I like go to
Hunter okay nice
they are sensitive aren't they is this
guy awesome as we can morph into
anything we can also spawn anything to
follow us around such ass make your
posse of anything you could ever want so
first we spawn the character and then
deep given what are we like and there
goes with goddamn car line well what
they spawn they might kitchen this kid
away from the fire response uh Michael
or Trevor I'm gonna give him know he was
kind of an hour why would like any of
these clothing options be together like
it really is random those do not belong
together hey it's Jim a chimp Jim get me
dragging his toes are really someone
like rubber band it is what I'm yeah
yeah futuristic so I'm allowed to have
seven I believe how about us like an
animal mascot okay
dear dear for sure oh no we gotta get
outta here guys oh no you got another
buggy yeah cuz I want I still 11 tea
with a knife okay so it's going down do
something I mean getting third person oh
no our mascot you [ __ ] oh damn you
getting weapons I gave a few of them
weapons all right what great job [ __ ]
we'll start off with this dude right
here monkeys they're not saving you Oh
food is gone okay go what were the ones
that fought did anything right into the
world with your energy weapons come on
the first I marry I think we're good on
the monkeys we're good um
Oh
so it out all right everyone here family
here sick John Wall monkeys it bins real
hey tried to jump out of bed all right
Mary moving on we got some more stuff
here police partners so pick C please
and we're going to spawn them
on them there is oh there she is gun
without funds out yeah girls depends how
[ __ ] oh the monkeys a cop all right oh
you got here so don't wait haha but
there really isn't a threat yet which is
why right
I'm sure what's happening I don't even
know
losing their mind aren't easy to follow
so if you know Sinclair there is there's
North Yankton which is the original
place when you first start the game it's
like the very first location that your
head yeah he's guys today they're so
attentive where we going Papa well
babies what let's go downtown and I'll
sugar no one here whoa oh I don't know
about guys oh no oh you just you got
scared ah boy we are gonna fix that toe
of yours we rule the world oh oh my boys
would love this right now Wow oh they're
chasing look at that you're you're
creating a little habitat here
whoa this is pretty dope they're so
adorable vana whale wow I'm back in then
you're all but you should take a kitchen
on phone to high grade all right not
really my crowd but what happened but
whatever they kill you beached all the
way no
they follow a fine mom are they oh I'm
giving birth kitty bird flying my baby
rebuilding sob dig do it start hunk oh
[ __ ] it's the worst flying it's like so
[ __ ] hard to do ok it's ok [ __ ] world
is your oyster Oh God can cats fly we'll
find out and do it
no I will yo good morning traffic is
pretty bad out there there's about six
home back whales and let's get to Sarah
in the sky Tara what is the driving
conditions yay I don't understand what
I'm seeing sheriff could you describe
what the 405 looks like morning Free
Willy is everywhere I am the damage done
I a master I'm with me come in my dear
welcome wait oh let's get it with a wake
of you whale wars have begun oh yeah
yeah yeah yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
you skipped a quail car easy easy yeah
it's loud [ __ ] yamir close
Oh what's your peril you want to get
into the car okay load it up ok kind of
do all of them absolutely yes yes yes
yes I don't take off don't pursue the
town is
ha ha
oh [ __ ] is right all right well um oh
the seagulls are out oh it's beautiful
day well everyone see you next time over
army